I'm afraid of two major things the first
thing is it's going to make a lot of
people redundant times are tough already
a lot of people are going to lose their
jobs I guess that's the Natural
Evolution of Technology the second issue
with AI is that it's moving so fast both
visually and from an audio standpoint
that there's going to be a lot of fraud
it opens up a whole can of worms people
could pretend to be other people's
family members and call them on the
phone and ask for money it could create
problems with elections for example
because we could see viral videos Deep
fakes of presidential candidates doing
certain things and the scary part is is
that AI is so Advanced that it knows
what the human wants and the human likes
there's a really great example of the
Drake song Drake in the weekend they had
the AI song which went super viral it
was amazing everybody loved it it knew
exactly what the audience wanted Drake
went to perform this live and people
actually preferred the AI version I
think that the Deep fakes are going to
be so powerful yes we might know at the
end of the day that this deep fake is
fake but the hype is still going to be
there the effects are still going to be
there a